[Musique]
l'adobe lagence de l'outre-mer pour la
mobilité est en souffrance en tout cas
est sur la sellette c'est la structure
destinée à encourager
mais ces reçus et la promotion des
travailleurs de nos pays est un
carrefour bonjour philippe jaquet
bonjour mon yacht en bon jour aux
auditeurs de martinez que la première le
président ben laden qui donc dans son
caddie ladom en difficultés financières
en difficultés de fonctionnement
difficultés de positionnement et voilà
ce que la cour des comptes vous dit on
arrête ce match là avec ces règles là
rapprochez-vous de pôle emploi comment
en est on arrivé à cette situation
or un rapide rappel historique la laddh
hommes a été transformée en
établissement public administratif au
1er janvier 2016 avec un passage
comptabilité publique en 2017
cela a entraîné quelques difficultés
dans la circulation de l'information la
fiabilité des règlements pour autant ce
qu'il faut retenir c'est que depuis 2015
la situation financière s'améliore la
cour des comptes indique que ça
s'améliore mais que ça reste fragile
ce constat nous le partageons puisque
les budgets qui sont alloués à la aladom
n'ont pas été suffisants pour permettre
notamment le renouvellement des
investissements informatiques et
numériques
car quelle hauteur les investissements
attendus lors de trois millions 2,3
millions trois cent premières
estimations parce que nous avons
aujourd'hui un outil informatique qui
n'est plus adaptée qui ne permet pas de
correspondre avec l'outil de la
comptabilité publique à laquelle nous
sommes passés depuis le 1er janvier 2017
cet outil ne permet pas de façon
automatique de remonter les informations
nécessaires pour l'obtention des
subventions européennes notamment celles
du fonds social européen et par ailleurs
il ne communique pas avec les nouveaux
outils parce qu'il est obsolète dès lors
qu'ils ne fonctionnent et à l'âge des
cavernes
voilà les noms mais l'anglais a
clairement il fallait il faut changer
cet outil on aurait dû commencer par là
faisant une photo minutes de 7,7 ladom
combien de personnes y travaillent quels
budgets et quels sont les plus gros
postes de dépenses alors ladom ses 127
équivalents temps plein pour reprendre
une expression administrative et c'est
plusieurs métiers et il faut il faut
insister sur ses métiers
le premier métier c'est la formation
professionnelle en mobilité et ça
mobilise des sommes conséquentes puisque
cela budget de l'ordre de 29 millions 24
millions pour l'état et 5 millions pour
les
collectivités ultramarines qui participe
avec en 2017 3574 actions de formation
avec il faut le dire quelques belles
réussites puisque nous avons 78 % de
taux de réussite a déçu des formations
et un taux d'insertion aci moi qui est
conséquent puisqu'il est alors de 65 %
donc ça c'est une très belle vitrine
donc l'asthme et ça fonctionne
uniquement parce que la dom assure un
suivi personnalisé et nous y reviendrons
au suivi personnalisé des parcours de
formation à la différence de pôle emploi
le deuxième métier de ladom qui est un
métier important c'est celui du
passeport mobilité études pour les
étudiants ultramarins qui partent les
études dans l'hexagone
et là aussi il faut noter que onze mille
huit cents étudiants ont bénéficié du
passeport c'est pas rien c'est un
chiffre significatif
la marque donc est dénoncée de toutes
non 84% boursiers là c'est un budget de
l'ordre de 13 millions et demi et la
dernière mission que la dom connaît que
les martiniquais connaissent bien et
apprécie beaucoup
c'est l'aide à la continuité
territoriale et là on est sur un budget
de 5 millions en deux et la on peut dire
que 20 1860 ultramarins ont bénéficié
des bons or sans la dom certains d'entre
eux n'auraient pas pu avoir un parcours
professionnel satisfaisant alors il y à
il ya aussi ce volet une fois qu'on
arrive à orly ou roissy sont la
compagnie il ya une prise en charge
également pour ces étudiants qui n'ont
peut-être jamais voyagé de leur vie
alors on le fait pas pour les étudiants
mais pour ceux qui viennent dans le
passeport mobilité formation et là il ya
un accompagnement personnalisé je vous
disais que ça va effectivement de
l'accueil à l'arrivée à l'aéroport
mais c'est aussi un suivi pendant la
formation quand les les jeunes et moins
jeunes sont en formation en province
ladom a noué des partenariats avec des
associations ultramarines et les zones
les jeunes ne sont pas isolés et par
ailleurs nous avons aladom cinq unités
territoriales six unités territoriales
dans l'hexagone ce qui permet d'assurer
un maillage l'accompagnement de
l'ensemble des stages elle travaille
quand ils sont à l'hexagone et j'insiste
beaucoup sur l'accompagnement
personnalisé des parcs on que fait la
doc
alors changement de statut il ya 4 5 ans
une mission qui reconnut des résultats
qui sont reconnues
dites vous mais pourtant il va falloir
fusionner avec pôle emploi
pourquoi tout simplement ne pas décider
kannad homme va changer un certain
nombre de choses une sorte de statu quo
mais en ayant conscience qu'il faut
faire évoluer les systèmes je voudrais
déjà rappelé que la cour des comptes ne
propose pas la fusion de ladom avec
collaboration récente coopération salade
de riz l'aliment ladom doit s'appuyer
sur les compétences de pôle emploi qui
sont l'emploi pourquoi pas quelques
d'autres parce que en matière d'acteurs
de la de l'emploi pôle emploi une
expertise
une qualité reconnue donc il n'est pas
stupide d'imaginer que nous puissions
nous appuyer sur leur expertise sur leur
outil informatique qui existe avec hélas
j'insiste beaucoup d des outils à
développer pour des passerelles de
communication entre mais pourquoi ne pas
mettre sur la table de l'argent qui vous
permettrait d'être autonome et de
continuer votre mission puisque vous
connaissez la meilleure vous avez vous
invite vous avez certainement raison
vous connaissez la la situation de
contrainte budgétaire de l'état ouais
et donc aujourd'hui il se dit que
investir 3 millions 5,4 millions sur
l'outil informatique alors que l'on peut
développer des passerelles avec pôle
emploi ça coûtera moins cher et je le
redis d'une fusion entre les assedic et
l'anpe et on voudrait j'aurais quand
même dire qu'il faut éviter d'avoir une
vision uniquement comptable de la
problématique de la formation des
ultramarins de l'internât cour des
comptes à ce matin oui parce que là
parce que la donne aujourd'hui assure
l'égalité de traitement entre les
ultramarins et leurs concitoyens de
l'hexagone en matière de formation
originelle nous ne pouvons pas avoir à
sur les territoires ultramarins
l'intégralité des offres de formations
qui existent dans l'hexagone donc il est
il est indispensable que ce soit
maintenu et je dis que nous avons un
savoir faire qu'il faut qu'il faut
développer dans le contrat gagnant
gagnant là qui ce qui se profile qui
risque de perdre peu plus alors déjà
déjà la cour des comptes fait des
propositions à des préconisations
si dans les trois îles il répondait pas
favorablement à ses propositions vous
serez offre encore comment ces
difficultés dit la cour des continents
alors je vais peut-être rectifier un
petit peu la cour des comptes n'a pas
encore les derniers chiffres 2000
2018 mais la donne a eu des résultats
qui ont évolué avec des pertes
effectivement 2015 des pertes
conséquentes en 2015 une amélioration en
2016 2017 un résultat excédentaire en
grande partie liée au fait que la dame a
cédé son siège historique et en 2018
nous avons un résultat estimé provisoire
aujourd'hui nombre de six millions
donc c'est une information que la la
cour des comptes n'avait pas au moment
de son passage et pour une raison très
simple c'est que nous avons à ladom
développer plus de demandes de
subventions auprès de l'europe et nous
avons travaillé avec des outils qui sont
obsolètes mais nous avons pu mobiliser
plus de fonds européens et c'est une
dynamique dans laquelle nous nous sommes
inscrits au conseil d'administration que
je veux leur président depuis juin 2016
pour faire en sorte que la spécifité de
ladom sont reconnues oui elle est ce que
pendant plus à gagner de là dedans
wood c'est ce que j'avais elle se
rappelle il sort quand même d'une fusion
entre les assedic et l'anpe qui était
quand même pas mal a demandé du temps
pour être digéré cette histoire est
maintenant on va leur mettre la donne je
voulais vous dire c'est que le rapport a
évoqué le rapprochement est évoqué par
la cour des comptes je ne sais pas s'il
fait l'unanimité après l'emploi
donc c'est une proposition de delacour
dire on vous en avait envie
personnellement finit bien non je pense
qu'il faut simplement développer des
coopérations en matière d'outils
informatiques faire en sorte qu'on a un
dossier unique et que choisir et vous
servir et viser leurs machines homme et
il n'est pas qu'il n'y ait pas de
ressaisie qui n'est pas leur saisie d'un
dossier et que parcourent plus fluide
mais je pense qu'il faut combiner les
créatifs des heurts éclatent is de
l'autre j'insiste aussi sur un point
important la dom s'inscrit toujours dans
les dimanches de formation qualifiante
aboutissant à des avances de diplôme ou
le titre professionnel pour l'emploi
dans une logique d'employabilité
donc on n'est pas toujours une formation
qualifiante c'est une différence
fondamentale et le bas ventre et le dos
et du lapin alors non je dis simplement
qu'il faut bien prendre en compte les
spécificités de la dom et les
spécificités des besoins d'information
des ultramarins et je voudrais aussi
insisté sur une
une problématique qui est qui remonte
régulièrement sur le rôle de la dame sur
le retour des des gens partir formation
il faut noter qu'aujourd'hui nous
travaillons en lien avec d'autres à ce
retour parce que il nous est reproché de
remplir des favorisés si nécessaire vous
a favorisé le départ de nos cerveaux moi
je peux donner quelques chiffres sur la
martinique par exemple quelques chiffres
des actions de passeport mobilité
formation en 2013
y'avait 1087 passeport mobilité en
martinique 2014 1254 2010 7 702 et 2010
c'est dire que l'évolution est assez
contrastée et comme vous avez une bonne
mémoire vous savez pourquoi en 2013 et
2014 il y avait ce pic on n'aurait pas
pu tout simplement supprimer la double
non parce que la dame répond vraiment à
un besoin
la formation mobilité et puis la
formation mobilité ce n'est pas
seulement inscrire les gens n'allaient
pas en cours de formation
ce n'est pas simplement trouver et
acheter la formation si aussi mais c'est
vrai c'est aussi le transmanche oui
c'est aussi l'accompagnement sur place
et c'est aussi l'aide à l'installation
qu'avait assad hommes c'est aussi le
complément de rémunération qui va c'est
par là d'hommes et tout ça aujourd'hui à
l'état pour l'emploi n'est pas en
capacité de le faire
philippe jacq il faudra faire preuve de
diplomatie et combien de temps pour
trouver une harmonie entre pôle emploi
et ladom est-ce que je ne joue pas
contre vous non je crois je crois
vraiment que les résultats 2018 de ladom
vont nous permettre de passer le cap à
ce que la cour des comptes était
inquiète sur l'évolution à très long
terme 2019 était pour eux un obstacle et
une grande difficulté nous pensons nous
aladom avec le conseil d'administration
et la direction générale et les équipes
de ladom que nous pouvons passer ce cap
il faut certes des investissements plus
mesuré il faut un accompagnement un
partenariat avec pôle emploi un
partenariat gagnant gagnant
peut-être qu imaginer que la donne soit
1 cotraitant de pôle emploi mais
cotraitant ouais on a déjà des
expériences par ailleurs
dernière question très rapidement
philippe jacq cette zone de turbulence
sera préjudiciable aux personnes qui
auraient pu bénéficier des aides de
ladom en ce moment non pas du tout la
turbulence c'est ça qui sera tifo
administratif
c'est un rapport de la cour des comptes
qui je rappelle souligne l'amélioration
des performances de ladom qui insiste
sur la fragilité de notre performance
mais qu'ils insistent beaucoup sur
l'amélioration en cours
merci philippe jacot rappelle que vous
êtes président de l'ademe la chance de
l'outre-mer pour la mobilité structure
en souffrance comme un mandat va le dire
merci d'abriter ce matin dans son crédit
bonne journée le journal